le f16 fighting falcon est l'un des plus
remarquables chasseurs de la fin du
xxème siècle
conçu par general dynamics il fait
partie maintenant de la gamme de
lockheed martin
il a été développé depuis un concept
expérimental de chasseur léger et il a
évolué vers le rôle de chasseur tout
temps et d'avions d'attac de précisions
le f16 et construit depuis cinq centres
de production séparer faisant de lui le
plus important programme d'avions
d'attac occidental plus de 4000 f 16 ont
été construits et la production continue
encore
c'est en 1965 que l' us air force a
commencé à formuler ses besoins pour des
chasseurs à haute performance
ceux ci incluait le fx à un intercepteur
chasseurs de supériorité aérienne lourd
et un chasseur d'urnes léger adf
le fx devait être un avion de chasse de
la classe des 20 tonnes équipé d'un
radar performant et sophistiqué est
aussi équipé de missiles longue portée à
guidage radar
l'adf devait se présenter comme un avion
d'environ 12 à 15 tonnes avec un
excellent rapport masse poussée et une
charge horaire adapté pour lui donner
une supériorité sur les performances du
mic 21 d'au moins 25%
le concept général de l'adf relevait de
la même réflexion menée après la guerre
de corée et qui déboucha sur le f 104
starfighter l'apparition en 1967 du mig
25 capable d'atteindre mach 2 8 et freya
les analystes du département de la
défense et modifia la planification des
futurs chasseurs de l'air force les
hautes performances de vars primordial
le concept fx abouti au mc donnel
douglas f-15 à un biréacteur à
l'avionique performante et est doté de
missiles longue portée
le programme adf fut temporairement mise
en sommeil
l'idée d'un chasseur léger ressurgit au
début de 1970 sous la forme d'une fiche
programme lwf ou chasseur léger qui fait
soumises aux industriels le 16 janvier
1972 elle précisait les besoins d'un
rapport masse puissance un point en
charge inférieur à 10 tonnes et une
manoeuvrabilité exceptionnel aucune
velléité d'égaler les performances du
mic 25 mai était spécifié l'accent étant
porté sur les performances en combat
aérien à des altitudes de 30 à 40 mille
pieds et à des vitesses comprises entre
mac 0,6 et mac 1,6
les points importants étant
l'accélération le taux de virages et
l'autonomie plus que les hautes vitesses
une petite taille était aussi requise
les mig 17 et 21 avaient montré au
vietnam qu'ils étaient difficiles à
détecter visuellement en combat la fiche
spécifié trois objectifs principaux
l'avion devait tirer partie pleinement
des nouvelles technologies réduire les
risques et les incertitudes du
développement et de la production et
prendre en compte les options
technologiques des besoins militaires
futures
avec la sélection du f 15 eagle pour le
programme f x les ingénieurs de general
dynamics se sont concentrés sur la
définition du chasseur léger dévolu au
combat aérien deux jours avec un
équipement électronique minimale l'étude
ainsi mené l'a été sous la désignation
constructeur de modèles 401 le résultat
de ce travail fut le y avait seize conçu
et construit à fort worth au texas
sous la direction de william dit elimane
joseph ce avec harry il à coeur comme
ingénieur en chef le général dynamics
modèle 401 a été étudiée sous forme de
maquettes et des douzaines d'essais en
soufflerie ont permis la définition de
la configuration finale de l'avion et
n'y eu aucune tentative de pousser
l'intégration des technologies avancées
spécifiques
là où elle n'était pas nécessaire les
technologies plus anciennes éprouvé
furent largement employé l'ensemble a
été conçu pour en faciliter la
construction avec l' usage de matériaux
conventionnels peu onéreux partout on ce
fut possible dans l'idée de baisser ses
coûts de production une grande partie
des éléments devaient être compatible
avec les avions déjà en service ou
encore à l'état de projet les
technologies avancées ont été utilisées
seulement dans les cas où elle était
nécessaire pour atteindre les objectifs
de performance requis
general dynamics décida d'utiliser un
seul réacteur de type f 100 au lieu des
2 general electric
y j 101 qui était utilisé pour le projet
concurrent de northrop un simple f100
permettait une consommation de carburant
inférieure à une paire de y j 101 et les
études ont révélé que cette
configuration monoréacteur n'aurait que
peu d'influencé sur la sécurité des vols
cette solution permettait en outre
d'obtenir une masse totale en ordre de
combat de huit tonnes tandis qu'une
configuration avec deux y j 101 aurait
entraîné une masse supérieure à 10
tonnes pour la même configuration de vol
durant les études préliminaires du f16
général dynamic étudiait les options de
simples et double dérive
la configuration avec une double dérive
entraînait des complications techniques
tandis qu'une dérive unique montra toute
satisfaction à condition qu'elles soient
suffisamment dimensionné
les études furent menés intensivement
sur la configuration de l'entrée d'air
avant que sa position définitive sous le
nez ne soit fixée la position ventrale
de l'entrée d'air a été choisi pour que
l'alimentation en air du réacteur soit
assurée même à grande incidence
l'entraîneur était à l'origine situé
sous le menton de l'avion mais
progressivement elle a été reculée pour
alléger l'appareil jusqu'au moment où
cette progression fut stoppée par la
nécessité de la maintenir en avant du
train d'atterrissage
ce positionnement sous le fuselage n'a
pas que des avantages
il représente un danger potentiel pour
le personnel au sol et soumet évidemment
le réacteur au risque d'ingestion de
corps étrangers des pierres et des
débris se trouvant sur une piste
cependant l'absorption des gaz du tir au
canon et éviter et le train
d'atterrissage reste protégé pour des
raisons de poids et de complexité
l'entrée d'air fx4 forme d'aile ont été
envisagés aile droite en flèche à
géométrie variable et en delta une aile
droite à faible flèche a finalement été
choisie car elle apporte la meilleure
combinaison de bonnes manoeuvrabilité
capacité de fortes accélérations et
porte ans maximum pour garantir de
bonnes performances en altitude
l'équipe de conception choisi in hell à
cambrure variable contrôlé par
ordinateur équipé de volée de courbure
en board attaque et de flap rond en port
de fuite qui servent à adapter la
conclure de l'ale aux conditions de vol
afin de maximiser son efficacité
les elle était trop mince pour recevoir
les éléments du train d'atterrissage
principal celui ci fut donc installé
sous le fuselage avec les logements pour
les roues elle est constituée
principalement d'aluminium avec quelques
parties en acier en titane et en
matériaux composites
le f16 et doté de commandes de vol
électriques un certain nombre d'éléments
ont été ajoutés pour permettre aux
pilotes de supporter jusqu'à 9 g un mini
manche situés sur une console latérales
et un siège éjectable incliné vers
l'arrière de 30 degrés la verrière est
une bulle autorisant un champ de vision
de 360 degrés même si le programme lwf
ne spécifiait qu'un minimum
d'équipements électroniques
l'équipe de conception reconnu qu'un
avion opérationnel exigerait
probablement un équipement de ce genre
plus lourd et plus volumineux
la décision fut prise de dimensionner
l'avion pour lui permettre d'emporter
les missiles à guidage infrarouge
sidewinder plus un canon m 61 et
anticiper les éventuels besoins d'emport
du missile à guidage radar sparrow
sachant que les pilotes du f16 préféré
utiliser le carburant des réservoirs
externes additionnel pour gagner la zone
de combat et revenir en consommant le
carburant des réservoirs interne
l'équipe de conception adapta le volume
des réservoirs interne et réduisant
ainsi la taille du fuselage allégea au
passage l'avion de 700 kg sur sa masse à
vide et de 1700 kg sur la masse en
pleine charge
ainsi le taux de virage fut augmentée de
10% et l'accélération de 30%
l'interchangeabilité des gouvernes de
profondeur gauche et droite et d'effets
l'apron réduisit le coût de l'avion
une grande partie des éléments du train
d'atterrissage sont communs à chaque
côté l'avionique et simple et l'armement
constitué d'un canon à tubes rotatif de
20 mm m 61 à 1 et 2 2 ième 9,6 winder en
bout d'aile ainsi que deux points dans
port de charges sous chaque aile
le prototype du y f-16 fut présenté
officiellement le 13 décembre 1973 à
fort worth et fut ensuite transportée à
la base des lois hartz le 8 janvier 1974
son premier vol fut un bon involontaire
entre les mains du pilote d'essai fils
est richert lors d'un essai de roulage
sur piste le 21 janvier 1974 en raison
d'une vitesse de roulage trop importante
au cours de cet essai la queue de
l'appareil frotte à la piste
deux choix s'offriront alors au pilote
sortir de la piste ou s'envoler il
choisi la seconde option et sauve a
vraisemblablement tout le programme le
premier vol officiel fut retardée le
temps de remplacer le stabilisateur
droit il eu lieu le 2 février 1974
toujours avec phil est riche et
recommande lequel atteint lors la
vitesse de 800 kilomètres heure et
l'altitude de 10000 m à deux occasions
lors de ses premiers vols d'essai le
recteur f100 se bloqua en position
ralenti obligeant le pilote alors à
l'atterrissage forcé des restrictions de
vols temporaire furent imposées au
prototype
tant que le problème ne serait pas
corrigé le f16 devait rester en vol à
une distance de l'aérodrome nuit
permettant de l'atteindre en vol plané
la panne était due à une valve
d'alimentation en carburant qui se
bloquer dans la position gaz réduit
à l'intérieur de l'air force des voix
s'élevaient contre le lwf arguments
qu'il pouvait être une menace contre le
projet et f15 pour faire taire les
suspicions le programme lwf fut
rebaptisé air combat fighter chasseurs
de combat aérien par le département de
la défense
au même moment les gouvernements belge
néerlandais danois et norvégien
envisager le remplacement de leur f 104
g starfighter ils formèrent
multinationales fighter program groupe
pour lui choisir un successeur
les candidats initiaux étaient le y f17
de chez northrop le dassault mirage f1
le saab
jia 37 viggen et le general dynamics f
16 le vainqueur du programme air combat
fighter deviendrait le candidat idéal
mais le mfp g voulait savoir si lui et
ses forces allaient acheter l'avion
avant de prendre une décision
ces nations exigèrent une décision de
l'us air force pour décembre 1974 le 13
janvier 1975 john mack lucas ministre
des forces aériennes annonça que le y et
16 étaient sélectionnés comme vainqueur
de la compétition acf l'air force pas ça
alors un contrat pour 50 avions de
présérie deux versions seraient
construites monoplace baptisée f 16a et
biplace f-16 b
une grande partie de la décision de
sélectionner le f16 résida dans ses
réacteurs f100 les mêmes que ceux du
f-15 l'achat en grande quantité de ces
réacteurs permettait une économie sur le
développement du f 15 qui était l'avion
que désirez réellement l'air force
les considérations politiques n'étaient
pas non plus absente alors que la
production des f 111 touchait à sa fin
general dynamics avait grand besoin des
commandes du f-16 pour maintenir son
centre de fort worth en activité à cette
même époque le f 16 étaient toujours en
compétition pour le nouvel avion de
combat de l'us navy
la proposition de general dynamics était
un monoplace embarqué basé sur une
cellule de f16 b
la place libérée au niveau du second
siège permettait d'installer plus de
carburant ou d'avionique mais en mai
1975 la marine annonça qu'elle
n'achèterait pas de f16 navalisée mais
optait à la place pour un avion issus du
y f17 qui devint plus tard le f à 18
hornet
en février 1975 l'otan proposer le f16
au prix de 5 millions cent soixante
mille dollars l'unité
tablant sur un total de production de
2000 avions comprenant ceux de l' us air
force et d autres pays dont l'otan
parallèlement le gouvernement américain
annonçait qu'il autorisait le transfert
de la technologie du réacteur f100 vers
ces pays
du coup en mai 1975 le y avait seize
effectua son premier vol transatlantique
pour une tournée commerciale chez ses
clients potentiels membres de l'otan et
fit une apparition remarquée au salon du
bourget cette année là le 7 juin 1975
confortée par l'acquisition de
l'appareil par l' us air force
la belgique les pays bas le danemark et
la norvège annoncèrent l'acquisition du
f16 comme remplaçant du f 104 le contrat
portait sur une production initiale de 3
148 avions le f16 proposait une
technologie et les performances
supérieures à ses concurrents et des
possibilités de production bien plus
attractive
bien sûr il y eut quelques critiques
notamment sur le manque d'un système de
détection longue portée et sur l'absence
de capacités tout en quelques-unes
portait également sur les problèmes de
performances que connaissait alors le
moteur
un important réseau de sous traitants
pour la fabrication sous licence du f-16
en europe fut constitué l'assemblage
final étant effectuée à gosselies en
belgique et à l' usine fokker de
schiphol aux pays bas de la même manière
qu à fort worth au texas
la production commence à en 1978
la construction du premier f 16 de série
commença à fort worth en août 1975
ceux-ci amnat general dynamics dans une
modernisation majeure de son énorme
usine laquelle avait été construite
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale pour
la fabrication des baies 24 liberator
cette usine en effet n'avait pas été
rénovée depuis les années 60
les f-16 à deux séries différent du et
grecs f-16 par leur fuselage allongé de
66 cm 25 cm en milieu de fuselage pour
permettre une plus grande charge de
carburant et 41 cm dans le nez pour
s'adapter aux radars westinghouse apg 66
la surface l air est augmenté de 6
mètres carrés et un point d'emport
supplémentaires sous chaque elle est
installée
au total 9 point d'emport sont
disponibles trois sous chaque l1 à
chaque bout d'elles est un point central
sous le fuselage autorisant jusqu'à
quatre tonnes 5 de carburant ou
d'armement
le stabilisateur horizontal a été
agrandi et le réacteur f100 équipé d'un
démarreur autonome
en 1977 leur force annonça sa volonté
d'acquérir 783 f16 a et b
supplémentaires
en spécifiant que ses avions étaient
destinés au rôle de chasseur bombardier
en contradiction avec le programme
initial lwf qui concernait un chasseur
d'urnes et léger
le tout premier f 16a de série sorti des
chaînes de fort worth et fit son premier
vol en août 78 le premier vol d'un f16
européens en l'occurrence un biplace eu
lieu le 11 décembre 1978 à gosselies
les premiers f16 a et b sont livrés aux
380 8e tactical fighter wing sur la base
de ville dans l'utah en janvier 79
la force aérienne belge reçoit ses
premiers exemplaires
au même moment le premier ssd pays bas
est livrée en juin 79
les livraisons pour le danemark la
norvège et israël débute en janvier 1980
en juillet de cette année-là le surnom
fighting falcon le faucon combattants
est adoptée officiellement
au moment de son entrée en service en
1979 il était prévu que son successeur
arrive en 1999 pour de nombreuses
raisons économiques comme politiques
le f 16 ne sera pas remplacé ni retirer
du service avant de nombreuses années
pour maintenir le même niveau de
capacité opérationnelle et d'efficacité
des avions existants pour les dix ou
vingt prochaines années un important
programme de modernisation a été
entrepris le mid life of debt aimé lui
mise à jour en milieu de carrière
le projet commence à en 1989 avec deux
années d'études des possibilités
d'amélioration des f-16 la phase de
développement débuta en mai 1991 il
continua jusqu'en 1997
les cellules de f 16 ont été soumises à
des charges et à des accélérations
supérieurs aux évaluations de 1979 et en
a résulté un certain nombre de ruptures
de cellules en vol et la découverte de
criques sur de nombreux avions avant
d'être rénovée dans le cadre du chantier
aimé lui l'état de l'aéronef est
examinée et avant d'entreprendre le
chantier de mise à jour il est réparée
si nécessaire
après ce processus les avions sont
capables d'effectuer au moins 5000
heures de vol supplémentaires et
continuer leur carrière opérationnelle
au delà d'une trentaine d'années
toutes les cinq visites d'entretien les
avions sont dépouillés de tous leurs
équipements et réassembler afin d'y
exécuter nombre d'opérations incluant le
remplacement des centaines des harnais
électriques le cockpit en comportant une
centaine à lui tout seul
tout au long de sa vie le f16 a été
utilisé pour des tests destinés à aider
les ingénieurs à comprendre certains
aspects du vol par exemple en février
1982 general dynamics a proposé une
version du fighting falcon avec une
modification radicale de sa voilure
celle ci était à l'origine destiné aux
avions de ligne supersonique
le projet fut dévoilée comme le s&amp
programme de croisières et d'évolution
en super sonic et ensuite porta le nom
de f16 xml delta avait une forme de
flèches irrégulière avec un total de 58
mètres carrés le double de la surface
des ailes d'un fc standard les objectifs
de cette recherche inclus et
l'exportation de forme et de profils des
l'innovant efficace en vol de croisière
supersonique tout en autorisant une
agilité de chasseurs dans les domaines
transsonique au delà de mach 1
pour cela elle fut conçue pour avoir une
très faible traînée en eau subsonic et à
vitesse supersonique sans dégrader la
manoeuvrabilité à basse vitesse
le programme f 16a poussée vectorielle
multiaxes commença comme une initiative
conjointe sur fonds propres de general
electric et de general dynamics l'us air
force avait refusé de financer ces
essais les deux compagnies se sont donc
tournés vers israël lequel et est
hautement intéressés par cette capacité
pour ses propres f 16
entre temps le laboratoire ait de l' us
air force se déclara enfin intéressés
par cette recherche est il pris une part
active alors qu'israël s'en retirer en
au même moment de general dynamics
obtenu un contrat pour développer un
avion de simulation de tests de
stabilité variable en vol
l'objectif incluait la démonstration de
l'utilité tactique de la poussée
vectorielle en combat aérien rapproché
l'avions démontré sa capacité à
conserver un angle d'attaqué stabiliser
de 80 6 degrés et une incidence
instantanée jusqu'à 180 degrés en
d'autres termes l'avion pouvait voler en
marche arrière pendant un bref instant
la poussée vectorielle apporte un
avantage significatif dans la rapidité
avec laquelle il est possible de se
placer en position de tir mais le vol au
grand angle d'attaqué est seulement
considéré comme une solution désespérée
en combat aérien
tout pilote de chasse qui se respecte
sait que le succès en combat dépend de
la bonne gestion de la vitesse et de
l'énergie pas en s'immobilisant plein
ciel même si c'est spectaculaire
un des développements principaux du f16
fut l'amélioration de ses capacités tout
temps et nocturnes
quelquefois présenté comme le night
falcon faucon nocturne
ce nouveau f 16 a paru en 1989 et le
land qui en constituent le coeur de ces
nouvelles capacités
le lan tierney un système constitué de
deux pods qui autorise des équipages à
utiliser leurs avions de jour comme de
nuit et dans les conditions météo les
plus difficiles
il comporte un radar de suivi de terrain
et un système de visée à infrarouge
diriger vers l'avant le flir qui
collecte les informations pour le
système d'armes de l'avion et désigne
les cibles avec un laser le désignateur
laser illumine les cibles pour les
bombes guidées laser ou gbl
il peut être aussi utilisé pour détecter
et suivre les cibles terrestres mobiles
pour le compte des missiles à gm 65
mavericks
il est même possible de désigner
plusieurs cibles pour plusieurs
mavericks qu'il est alors possible de
tirer au cours d'un même passage une
autre usage du laser et de déterminer la
distance exacte avec un point de repère
afin de recaler le système de navigation
inertielle de l'avion ceci est
indispensable pour atteindre une cible
sans références visuelles
on
le collimateur -gc marconi a été la
réponse pour lui et ses forces à sa
demande pour une visualisation tête
haute
capable d'afficher une image infrarouge
issus du flir du lantern la conception
de ce a chuté a été un véritable
challenge
les optiques conventionnelle
n'autorisait pas l'intégration de ces
données sur une vitre d'une telle taille
on appliqua donc les nouvelles
technologies telles que l'holographie on
s'assurera également que le a chuté
n'interférait pas avec la ligne
déjections c'est à dire qu'il laissait
suffisamment de place pour laisser
passer les genoux et les pieds d'un
pilote en train de s'éjecter
dans le cas du f16 le collimateur sert
de pare-brise pendant cette séquence car
la verrière d'une seule pièce est
complètement éjecté exposant ainsi le
pilote au vent relatif la glace du a
chuté doit être également suffisamment
solides pour y résister elle même à tel
point qu'on a retrouvé plusieurs
collimateur en parfait état dans des
épaves de f16 qui s'était écrasé les
potes lanternes sont installés juste
sous l'entrée d'air le pote de
navigation est à gauche
lana ciel de désignation est à droite le
pote de navigation comporte le radar de
suivi de terrain et un flir tandis que
le pote de désignation est équipé d'un
autre flir et du désignateur laser le
lantern possède une interface avec les
commandes de vol car il est capable
d'assister le pilote en mode suivi de
terrain
en plus du lantern le nouvel f-16
possède un circuit de respiration sous
pression pour améliorer la tolérance aux
jets du pilote l'alimentation nécessaire
pour les contre mesures électroniques
internes et un collimateur de tir canon
améliorer la capacité d'engager des
cibles terrestres mobiles
la section de l'arrière du fuselage
permet d'y installer aussi bien le de
general electric f100 ou le pratt &
whitney eve 105e ces moteurs ne soient
interchangeables
la cellule est renforcée pour supporter
9 g à la masse de 13 tonnes au lieu de
12 et la masse maximum au décollage est
porté à 19 tonnes
les jambes du train d'atterrissage sont
rallongés pour augmenter la garde au sol
des deux potes de lanternes et est
renforcée pour supporter le poids
supplémentaire les trappes du 30 et et
galbées pour laisser de la place aux
roues plus larges
tandis que les feux d'atterrissage ont
été déplacés sur la trappe du train
avant 615 night falcons ont été délivrés
à l'ufr force mais aussi aux forces
aériennes de turquie du bahreïn d'israël
et d'égypte
les f-16 ces blocs 50 52 sont en
production
il comporte un réacteur aux performances
améliorées soit le f110 ge 129 pour le
bloc 50 ou le f100 pw 229 pour le block
52 le f100 pw 229 est plus léger et plus
puissant que les f 100 ancienne
génération
il délivre 13 tonnes de poussée apparue
fin 1990 la production de cette version
est toujours en cours et devrait
s'étendre au delà de 2005 avec les
derniers avions délivré à la grèce et à
israël
le premier f16 block 50 a été livré à us
air force en novembre 91 en 1997 plus de
300 l'avait suivi pour quatre clients
différents
les blocs 50,52 commandé après 1996
comporte des éléments du ml comme les
écrans multifonctions en couleurs
l'enregistreur vidéo tribande et
l'ordinateur de mission modulaire
le bloc 50 50 de plus est une version
qui possède la capacité d'emport de
larmes de mcdonnell douglas le jdm joynt
direct attaque munitions la mise à jour
comprend une antenne sur la dérive
contenant un radar à ouverture
synthétique autorisant le guidage des
bombes marque 83 de mes livres
les marques 84 de 2000 livres et les
baies du sang neuf de 2000 livres
également un détecteur passive dallaire
domicile avec un système de navigation à
référencement de terrain et l'équipement
pour accueillir les réservoirs conformer
de 2271 litres sur les flancs du
fuselage
on trouve aussi un système de génération
d'oxygène embarquer un système de visée
de casque une batterie de contre mesures
internes
le radar northrop grumman apg 68 lequel
apporte des améliorations sensibles en
matière de portée de résolution
d'évolution et de tolérance
de plus l'application de processus
techniques avancées améliore la capacité
du radar à opérer dans les
environnements électromagnétiques
intense et résister aux brouillages
mieux que les anciens modèles
l'un des derniers clients pour ses f16
et l'aviation grecque
après avoir envisagé de devenir
partenaire du programme eurofighter
typhoon la décision d'acquérir 50 f16
block 52 avec une option de 10
supplémentaires a été révélée en juin
2000 est passé en septembre 2001
la commande est constitué de 40
monoplace et 20 bis place de l'asu
version 52 équipes et des réservoirs
conforme
le développement du f 16 de chasseur
léger à chasseurs bombardiers implique
sa capacité à emporter une grande
diversité d'armement
en mission de combat aérien il emporte
aussi bien des missiles à moyenne portée
que des seuils winder à courte portée
ces armes permettent au f-16 de
combattre aussi bien au delà de la
portée visuelle du pilote qu'en combat
rapproché
il emporte également un canon m 61
vulkan de 20 mm le f 16 ans porte une
large gamme d'armes air-sol comme le
missile mavericks et le missiles
anti-radar armes
dans ses fonctions de bombardier le f 16
ans porte une combinaison d'armement
incluant des armes à guidage laser
pesant jusqu'à 2000 livres chacune
les f-16 emporte la bombe jdm de
mcdonnell douglas de 2000 livres qui
furent employées pour la première fois
lors des combats contre l'irak
en outre cette panoplie d'armements est
complété par des armes non guidés tel le
gator conteneurs à sous munitions et les
lance roquettes
cette remarquable polyvalence en matière
d'armement sur un avion d'une taille
modeste explique la grande popularité du
f16 dans les forces aériennes dans le
monde entier
mais il est aussi très apprécié du grand
public lors de ses apparitions dans les
meetings aériens
il est la monture de la patrouille de
démonstration de l'ufr force les
thunderbirds
bien d'autres forces aériennes
l'utilisent également comme
démonstrateur
ici nous pouvons apprécier la fabuleuse
démonstration de remich ou keynes de la
force aérienne belge à brigue inéligible
en raison de la proximité de londres et
de l'aéroport niçois d'importantes
contraintes s'applique sur les
démonstrations effectuées par les
pilotes à begin et il
avec dextérité rudy parvient à maintenir
son f-16 dans les limites du périmètre
de l'aérodrome
grâce à la manoeuvrabilité de son avion
comme les belges sont basés à cette
occasion à manston rudy effectué
seulement un touch and go utilisant la
puissance considérable du f-16 pour
s'arracher de la courte piste de berne
il
que rudy soit détenteur du trophée
braking qui récompense la meilleure
démonstration en solo n'est finalement
pas vraiment une surprise
bien que le f16 soit maintenant service
depuis plus de 25 ans et il est prévu de
rester l'un des chasseurs principaux de
l'inventaire américain et celui de bien
d'autres nations alliées bien au delà de
2015 et restera opérationnel sans doute
après 2030
plus de 4000 f 16 ont été livrés à 24
pays incluant l'aviation américaine ce
qui fait de lui l'avion de combat le
plus populaire de sa génération et de
loin
beaucoup